how are you coping spiritually yeah it's
uh
it's insane i mean all you can do is
sort of take it day by day and it's
you know deal with things as they're
thrown in your direction
um i've really i've really this year
especially
i i think with everything going on plus
the pandemic
it's i've really i've really gotten to a
point where i have a better
understanding of
what is within my control and what is
outside of my control
so so the things that i can't control
i i've really i've really
learned the learned
the um the trait of
sort of within my control
knowing that all i can control is who i
am
who i choose to be within all of this
craziness um
so no matter what is sort of thrown at
me and what i have to deal with
yeah figuring out who i want to be and
then
dealing with all of it as that person
um it might not be it might not be the
easiest thing to do
uh but it's it's the road less traveled
for me
and and it i think it's less traveled
for a reason because it's hard
um but it just seems to be so much more
fulfilling at the end of it all you know
you
yeah it's interesting you say that
because at a time like this where you
are
more still and you're at home and you
have all that noise in your
head like you don't it's finding
yourself in being still and
the fact that you said you you figured
out how to choose who you are
that's a difficult one and i'm impressed
that you're able to do that at a time
like it is
it is difficult but uh but
so is life right now yeah it is
it's all difficult so it's like we might
as well i might as well
learn a trait and get good at something
during a time when i need it the most
um and now is the time
for that it's with with everything going
on with with
the kids with school with with just life
with things
shutting down and reopening and then
shutting down again it's kind of like
okay you know i i'm already on this
crazy
ride of life right now um i might as
well
choose to to handle it and be the person
that i want to be
during all of it um
and like i said it's not it's not always
the easiest
uh you know the the easier way i think
of dealings
with things sometimes is sort of you you
have your immediate emotional reaction
and you just do it but it doesn't that
doesn't always
turn out the best you know that's always
that that doesn't always serve the
situation the best so i i've been trying
to
take a step back and breathe for a
minute and go okay how do i
really what serves this situation the
best
uh who do i want to be not who am i
because
who i am is much more emotionally
charged and much more in the in the
minute of things and you want to get
you want to defend yourself when when
you you feel like you should you want to
do those things
but i don't want to look back on a
situation and go you know i felt good
for
30 seconds afterwards but uh
but that reaction didn't serve the
situation
the best it didn't serve myself it
didn't serve my kids
it didn't serve the people around me um
and so if i can if i can
teach people lessons by not teaching
by just doing and they they watch and
they go huh that's that's really cool
the way that was handled
um and they learn by example
that's that's great
because i i didn't necessarily have that
example when i was younger
and that's that's a great one to learn
and you know and i've learned it through
really adverse
adverse times this has been a really
tough year for me
it has been you just want 2020 to end
don't you
i do yeah i think i think everyone wants
20 2010
not that although i wanted 2019 to end
and i remember when 2020 started i was
like oh this is going to be a better
year
cut to 2020.
so i don't know i mean i i assume that i
wanted to end
i want i want this to end i'm curious to
see what the new
normal is yeah because i i don't think
when people say oh we're going to go
back to normal i don't ever think
normal is going to be again what it was
i think it's going to be something new
um but i'm open to that
i'm open to the experience i'm open to
seeing what it is and and and
and living with it and and finding my
comfort within it
i mean i don't have control of what it's
going to be i know and i have kids at
home right now and one of them i could
tell it's taken a toll on her mentally
it's finally hitting her hard
and yeah i mean how are your kids doing
right now like this
must be a struggle for them as well
yeah i mean the the remote learning
thing was the first
big uh big hurdle um
my six-year-old was great with it he was
fine he would
on his ipad he would check in before all
the other kids and he was like really
focused and he got it
and then my eight-year-old that just
wasn't his thing he
remote learning just did not work for
him he's
he's much more of a social individual
and
and so the idea of just sitting on an
ipad
and learning for
five hours a day he just didn't that
that just didn't work
for him um and you
as i'm sure you have too you learn that
the teachers that seem to work the best
are the ones that
figure out how to trick kids into
learning
in social situations
they involve the whole class and they
the class
learns without okay we're all going to
sit down and learn right now you don't
you don't give them a heads up you don't
give them an opportunity to
choose it just sort of the situations
and the things that they create
you know for the class teach just by
by way that the class works um
and so the kids now they have a
homeschool
teacher they're in a pod with six other
kids that they went
went to school to before went to school
with before
um they seem to be doing really well
they've had a much better year this year
than they did the end of last year for
sure i mean the end of last year was
uh you know in its defense it was
everyone just sort of trying to figure
out how to
finish out what they had already started
i i think with a little more
preparation this year it's been better
um
but i look forward to the kids being
back
at a school with playgrounds and all of
that
i look forward to that one of the
positive things though was the mass
singer
uh the finale is this week so i have to
ask because i am a fan
who do you think is going to win is it
going to be the sun the crocodile or a
mushroom
huh i have no idea i i the sun was in my
group
what was in my was in my my my group of
people
uh son is awesome son's an amazing
singer i
i'm not a betting man because that
doesn't work out very well for me
um every time i bet on black or red it
doesn't
it ends up being red um so it doesn't
i'm not one of those like
hey follow me to the winner's circle
because the i i
i haven't experienced much of the
winning the the winner circle
but um i would say from the people i
experienced
uh sun is gonna take it okay so who do
you think is the sun
i have no idea come on you have to have
someone in mind
i have nobody in mind i i think this is
leanne
that yeah that's been that's been the
guest that i think
is is the most spot-on she's an amazing
singer
an amazing performer um it's a real
unique experience to be in a costume and
be
anonymous is it's a really
interesting experience for people that
have lost
anonymity for for especially as long as
she has i mean
you know for her since she was a kid i
mean i get it like i
i sort of lost that as a kid also so
um i hope it's her just because
it's such a fun experience and i think
yeah i think she would get the most out
of it
and it's funny the fact that we can't
figure who it is and robin couldn't
figure out it was you
that's the giraffe even with the clues
yeah i know
but but singer and then dancer it's the
same way i've noticed like
you you watch these clue packages and
you sort of
you get stuck in your head who it might
be and i think
i think singer is almost tougher than
dancer that way because
you hear people sing you sort of you you
focus in on like oh well you know they
have an amazing voice so it must be
someone from this
from this group like this this area of
things
and you can be completely misled
by it and completely off um
that happened with robin with me i mean
he he
started in the right direction yeah oh i
recognize
i recognize that person's voice but i
can't put a face to it
and then he just completely strayed he
all of a sudden was like you know
he walks like you know someone that i
know it was like what
what happened to his voice i don't what
do you mean walks like you know that's
insane
um so i think in dancer
because it you have to be
you you have to pay closer attention to
the clues
and and the clues the clues can be
misleading but there are
aspects of the show that that keep the
ship
in going in the right direction we have
we have this uh this word up segment on
the show
where uh every time there's a
performance
whoever performs uh with the mic
completely unaltered says a word
and the word is in their own voice and
the word is a clue
that that pertains to that person so if
the word
is grammy and you've been on this
kick of like oh it's an it's it's an
olympian
right and then all of a sudden you hear
somebody say grammy and they have a
really deep voice you go okay well it's
obviously not an olympian at this point
so right
let me throw that away and let me let me
pay attention to other things
how they move how they walk out do they
seem like someone full of energy that's
younger someone that's older
you know do they do they pick up on
choreography really well and seem like
somebody that is a trained dancer or
does it seem like somebody that is
an entertainer or somebody that is an
athlete and has never done this before
in their lives so you start looking for
those crazy clues that make sense and
the more times you see somebody perform
the more times the more things you get
to put together and and
and and sort of mold the the direction
that you're going now you get to judge
alongside
polyp duel yeah well so so
the thing a that i love about this is
that we're not judging
it it's we're we're a panel and the idea
of this is
yeah the idea of the of the masked
universe which i like
is that it's not we don't judge anyone
we don't judge whether
performance was good or your technique
was right or not
it's not about that it's about
entertaining people and so
we want to we want to have as much fun
as a panel as the people do performing
and in costume and we want to
we sort of want to set the tone for the
people at home we want it to be a fun
experience
um and it really was the
the people that the people that have
been in costumes performing have had a
great time we had a great time as a
panel
craig robinson is the host he has a
great time hosting yeah
it really is just a positive experience
from the top down it really is and
it's really fun for me doing singer
like not knowing who was in a costume
uh nobody on set knows
who you are in the costume not even the
director of the episode knows
they call you by your costume so i was
known as giraffe
everywhere i went uh there there were
probably four people
that knew it was it was me because they
had to they offered it
so was the executive producer my agent
my manager
my attorney who set up the deal the
vocal coach there
the music the the head of the music
department there
so you have this small number of people
but literally you're completely
anonymous like i would go and do press
stuff and do photo shoots and all of
that
and everyone referred to me as the
giraffe and i couldn't speak to anyone
and it was great because it was really
it opens the door for you to have fun
and you realize like oh i can do all
this stuff
and nobody has a clue that it's me um
so it really it's the closest thing i
can compare it to
is halloween for people like you put on
a
costume and makeup and all this stuff
and you go out and you
you you know play the part of this
costume that you're wearing and
it's so much fun for that reason and you
and
that's why that to me is why people
enjoy
that holiday so much because you get the
opportunity to
if your costume is a zombie you get to
act like a zombie all night which is
and not be judged by people go oh he was
a great zombie
you know it's not it's not me walking
around being a zombie
it's like it's just a zombie live it's a
different experience